und wir schauen auf Bilder die die ganze
Welt jetzt sehen muss das sind Bilder
aus dem Iran Frauen die dort ihre
Kopftücher verbrennen es gibt kein
größeres kein eindrucksvolleres Symbol
für den mutigen Kampf gegen ein
islamisches Regime das unterdrückt als
diese Bilder
und diese Frauen die davon mehr als
genug haben von diesem Regime die sich
hier leben melden nicht mehr von
sogenannten Sittenwächtern diktieren
lassen wollen anlass für diesen großen
Protest auf den Straßen von Teherans der
immer mehr Zulauf findet ist der Angriff
auf diese mutige Frau sehen sie eben
gerade gesehen das ist Mesa armini eine
Frau die ihr Kopftuch nicht
vorschriftsgemäß trug wie die
Sittenwächter sagen die dann brutal
verprügelt wurde und wenig später in
einem krankenhausstab jetzt muss damit
Schluss sein das sagen immer mehr Iraner
Frauen und Männer wie dieser ja auch
Männer nämlich die ja längst mit auf den
Straßen sind und dieser hier wir haben
ihn hier eingekreist in der Mitte hier
ganz genau am Polizeiwagen geht erst
vorbei und schnappt dann einmal rein in
den Wagen er schnappt sich nämlich die
Handykamera das Handy des Polizisten der
nämlich filmt für die Sittenwächter
Werder auf den Straßen ist alle die die
da protestieren die sollen bestraft
werden der Handy beweist und dieser Mann
der ist so mutig und vernichtet diesen
Beweis das also sind die mutigen Männer
und vor allen Dingen Frauen in diesen
Tagen von Teheran
[Musik]